hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to one shot now I made
a horrible error I didn't close the game
the last time that I played I actually
left it open for a long time so if you
see the guy saying he's wasting so much
time because of me that's not my fault
it's just that it's exactly my fault so
I'm back I don't think anyone else is
noticing it either am I the only one
who's seeing this
I don't know Niko I don't know maybe I
just kind of left you alone there for a
long long time and that wasn't my
intention to do oh I forgot I need to
move through this one ok so I really got
to figure out where I need to go and the
only way that I can think to go and this
guy is probably very angry I'm losing so
much time I'm not even timing it anymore
hate this ok good
then you don't need to worry about me
losing time you just need to worry about
you to losing time so what I'm going to
do is the only thing that I know left to
do which is backtrack so I'm going to go
back a bit I don't know where I'm going
instead of that but I just know that if
I backtrack then maybe I can start from
the beginning at least follow my steps
nevermind and I want to go back I get it
Niko I understand you're very upset
about the amount of time that you've
wasted in this endeavor or that I've
wasted of you for you and hopefully we
can get somewhere that we need to go
hello interesting book you got that uh
oh it is written in the language I do
not recognize well what good does that
do that perhaps you should find a way to
decipher it when you're at the library
it may be of help I've no suited for
this guy I'm sorry ok but that's a good
clue because I know there's a library so
if I can decipher it then maybe that's
going to help me actually do what I need
to do and if I remember the library is
over here and then down a few hallway
and then should be not too far for me to
go with Niko here so soon as I can
decipher this mystery here maybe I can
solve why all this is happening hello
hey there hello you can Messiah hi know
about this ok thank you alright ok so
there's got to be a way to decipher this
somehow
cuz it's got to be the library right
this would not be the library right this
looks like a frickin library right I'm
not a fool this is a goddamn library
right it's a goddamn library oh you need
to find a way to get to the library on
the surface okay so I still don't know
exactly where I'm gonna go but at least
I should be able to do what I need to do
so maybe I can just start combining
random [ __ ] in my inventory because
maybe I have everything that I need a
magic meter
Magnus on set - aluminum weird film no I
ain't gonna combine with nut Oh what is
this where am I now
oh look at you there's a pair of
scissors on a grounding a pilot here
I don't think anyone is using it anymore
so how did I miss this I have no idea I
absolutely 100% mistress yeah maybe we
can make it button out of here second
kind of piece of the Canon folded into
rectangular shape just like arts and
crafts fine I don't think it's supposed
to be this simple
how we gonna connect it to the elevator
well let's find out there we go
now I got a goddamn button but the
aluminum ah what if I just followed the
magnets under this edge hmm
pulling together bits just barely I was
good enough and then I can goddamn stick
it with some goddamn douche damn tape
that makes so much more sense in all the
[ __ ] that I was - and ah okay I
didn't even realize that room even
freaking existed so it's not entirely my
fault but it is again entirely my fault
because after I started taking the
shortcut to the library or the cafe and
they're not really a library then I sort
of just kind of forgot that that existed
but now I need to go over to the tape
dispenser to be able to put some tape on
this bad boy over here and then finally
fix his goddamn elevators that shouldn't
have taken me time at all I was looking
for a piece of the recipe that I didn't
know existed I was trying to complete
the puzzle without all the pieces I'm a
big dumb doofus do is what I'm trying to
say the tape dispenser of course I got a
tape together am i fall apart good thing
marklar hey I'm here to help you as your
God I send my godly powers towards you
to help you along your way right then I
did that I think anyway
maybe I should staple it just for good
measure ok button need some good staples
on that now ok all right we'll just take
the tape and be on our way I didn't need
to waste 15 goddamn hours of Billy Buu
over there trying to get down to his jab
hopefully there's going to be ok because
this is one ramshackle City button if I
ever saw one that's right
so this works oh it ain't good ok
reactivating elevator services please
input security code to continue what
that's never happened before the squares
huh
you saw them right we were on the door
and oh no the square stuff happens all
the time I'm at the old security code
thing
then again the elevator hasn't been this
broken before hmm I guess we should go
look for a God marklar well wouldn't you
fricking know it six three oh one four
we have the code right here why would we
need to go any more six three oh one
four please input how about a little old
sex 301 or bloody big bloody boom bah Oh
Oh what do you know it I had everything
that I ever needed and it's all gone
right it works I don't know what you did
kid but it actually works good job kid
you're a genius you know that well I had
help from this God that talks to me
inside my brain that always held the
situation all right all Messiah business
okay yeah sure all right ready to go
I'll be up ahead all right I guess it's
gonna be okay
fine by me oh thank you for holding the
elevator door open from you mister no
prob hop in hop in squirt come on hop on
over here alrighty then I guess we're
going to take a nice elevator ride down
into the abyss
all right nice awkward silence as your
God did you notice the co that it's a
little awkward in here ah
you notice that boy okay re there sure
is taking a while
mm-hmm oh goodness gracious I'm stuck in
an elevator with the messiaen also
literally God themself
this is awkward well maybe we can chat
to pass something you heard me
I mean sure where i margall are should i
ahh resumed awkward silence I don't
decree you shall resume its how I think
properly this pleases me
not a peep you here
ha did you say something
cuz you better not have I'd have been
very mad and might have smited be I
could delete your files in a heartbeat
not hesitating alright good good good
job everybody good job being said anyway
it was nice meeting you
Nico right see you around kid gotta run
now I'm like 16 hours late for my job he
seems in a hurry
yes we should hurry to market bar people
are counting on us well let's go find
that library ok hello beep-boop
beep-boop
ok nice conversation we have hello you
are looking so dapper huh you're right
oh the Messiah perhaps this is a sign
the only do you think you can fix the
world with Masada me honestly I don't
know I've been getting mixed messages I
know but what do you think I think I
don't think the God in my head tells me
what to think I think I should listen to
marklar
as you should good job beside you've
been trained well after all marklar
helped me get this far I'll take your
faith for an answer then what do you
mean by that it means whatever you think
it means very very River Berber I'm so
boozie boozie water I find then where am
I headed off to where am I going
hope that plants is doing ok whole mazes
regrowing I'm not gonna follow you sign
I got my own way to go what is this hey
hey there you have a lot of fish
actually one in your face yeah I'm
worried about them Oh Clara something
about how the square particle stopped
just took out a major pipeline I guess I
should take advantage of the running
water while I still can ok alright then
now I'm not looking forward to that
water shortage ok the big fish tank big
fish tank
a big fish tank ok good bye
then oh hello anything knows even it
knows
are you here to purchase your coffee no
newspapers are for grown-ups
grown-ups as robot kid playing
stereotype from 1910 oh no a [ __ ] you're
talking about
yeah what does that mean these people
who aren't kids kids or aren't you a kid
other robot right okay all right then
wait
hello Messiah hi what service was
detected from the air grand access
elevator on Main Street
gravity issue quickly resolved itself
before investigators could take place
brain cells have been reported from
slums the source is unknown man Thurber
described as faint bleeding by the
area's residents
Oh a good infestation I am NOT certain
that this is evening but my life centers
are not taking daylight
I'll assume it is evening oh you go kid
go kids you keep going you do it you got
to do I understand I know that you know
what you're doing
and I appreciate what you doing and
that's good for everybody here hi how's
it going my name is Mark Clark hello
person the library is up ahead
Thanks okay so the library's right there
then when the world ends would it be
better if it was gone in an instant or
slowly fading away be honest I'd rather
the former alright fine I'm a little
depressing don't you think okay but if I
take my book into this library
supposedly all my mysteries are gonna be
solved but did and there's nothing on
the outside I was just doing a figure
eight for my own entertainment and to
please the God inside my brain hello is
anybody here translating the book okay
how about you what I didn't say anything
Subterra me then looking at your book
yes you were in the library there's
books in the library um
the bug the chatty went upstairs
Cather's books cover a wide range of
topics no subjects he does not write
about quite the Renaissance man don't
you think I guess so but he's been
focusing on documenting the world as of
late no they say the city is the last
bastion of civilization turn these books
maybe the only thing we have to remember
the rest of the world by ah that's sad I
love books on the ground I'll box on the
ground books are neatly placed on the
shelves
hello were you oh you need direction
let's see this area is mostly historical
records the reference section is
downstairs enough I'm not sure the
children's section is sorry that's okay
I'm not really looking for books oh are
you here to look for the off of them no
well that's good I mean that means you
won't be disappointed I've been
volunteering here for months and I've
never seen them not even one he works
with the head librarian on publishing so
you think you would least show up onto
the wild but he doesn't yeah he seems
kind of reclusive which is weird for a
guy who supposedly travels the world
maybe it's just around deeper monk a
computer is up but hopefully that's
gonna give me some disturbing cream
later on ah hello weird face the author
is so cool I already can travel all over
the world with vlogging that's how it
gathers materials for his books Wow
alright then leg you hello
um what are you doing to that book don't
worry dude - my own bucks than your own
I just pulled them off the shelves to
modify them I have crossed out some
sections most sections how come because
otherwise they think I copied him yonder
I mean I really don't see the point of
writing anything anymore
your authors he's gonna write about the
same thing and then everyone will love
it and nobody's gonna remember the book
that came out before held oh uh I mean I
ain't hatin I can see why people go nuts
over his stuff that guy's got major down
but it just hurts you know
it's never fun when people call you a
copycat for something you wrote about
first I can see that it would call me a
cat all the time even though I'm a
person cats are pets and mousers sure
all people don't think I eat mice hey I
guess we're in the same boat kiddo
alrighty then y'all be translate this
book even have skill to similar set my
fate I guess we can call the cat isn't
all that bad as long as people don't
assume you much we're good alright
goodbye
alright I gotta find a way to translate
this bill hello oh hello nerd robot
excuse me oh you are the Messiah
welcome when I first entered the city a
big robot told me to look for a library
on the surface the same library right
yeah very my deal oh goody
well we're here what do we do now the
big robot only said there be clues here
yeah is a question for the head
librarian your allow me to color
okay I'll wait here with the got inside
my head did you know that I talked to a
greater being and died my brain no okay
alright then so wait here not going
anywhere
she's not picking up
is she not here she's the errors using
the archival room theorem which is
contrary to her work she will ignore any
and all room called for several days
you go up and get her in person then
leaving is post is not only programming
and can I go myself
course your kind of room is available
through the stairwell by me gajju
Thanks okay I'm on my third cup I can't
feel my limbs but I have to de white
files and bogans um here the other let
it beautiful clippings okay alright then
pretty extreme for that cuz it won't be
bothering you anymore I gotta find who
and after an injury library card
required further actions blood library
card wired can I have a library card
down we're gonna get one this is a
question for the head librarian Church
allow me to call her Oh God hi oh boy
we're gonna be here awhile
she's not picking up
I figured are you sure you can't just
let me through letting it through
without a library card it's against my
programming
what even in an emergency my programming
is not flexible I have not been tamed
alrighty then fine be a stick-in-the-mud
you robot douche you have a good day
being all yes holy all right so I got a
fun book club
then remember seeing that before but
anybody want to give me that a library
card cause there's latest books is
really something here that librarian
just released a bunch last week well
they're big compendiums you'll see them
if you look around kind of different
from as earlier works up he was reading
his travel logs and novels mostly a big
book with black clover comprehensive
guide to phosphorus as a general rule if
a cost for loses its glow entirely it
cannot be religion less exposed to the
Sun if the posture is merely then it may
be possible to boost it through exposure
another phosphor of higher energy but
even so the booster Partho will never
return to its original ripeness
okay blue Barbara out of carbon fiber
blue phosphorus moderate levels of
energy and can exist in both organic and
mineral forms the mineral form is most
commonly found in the metallic kind of
the Barrens you organic form is most
commonly found in phosphorus remnants of
secretions although the light emission
is a blue Volvo is far away that's what
I would describe as itself from certain
properties that is to say the glare may
not be constant this one's a group of
problems suffering and left under tempo
along here at the time if you move out
rode about machine a motor should be
sent to the baseline level of activity
to ensure the constant agitation of the
Barbara operation can be used me mother
under my mother crippling identity in
order the recipe hypothesis I can only
find an organic form no no does include
a purpose behind bears most although the
BIOS presently lubricated ground
covering lofty claims it was only in my
new domestic most impossible cosmic
creep under whose how do you print off
loose however due to five relative
scarcity
the path of hostage there's really no
lava sauce Thank You Lily floating sink
I still have an occupy read off a
vikarma sausage bread pasta sauce in a
Jacuzzi in a menorah for Tony you like
when it's all you in Denali to develop
on in the city for scam can be hung
creating do switch art if you create
lobby for higher things but do not feel
bad rights will precipitate have been 22
debacle because I didn't grow due to
fermentation of oxygen is your physical
age Brittany yeah huh
[Music]
yeah hi what do you think about the
author I don't know
have you read it stuff yet if not you
should I'm trying I got a book it's not
translated
big bug with the black cover because
emergence of new act logical Nice's in
the post son world okay I didn't say
that oh the aquatic investor the most
money micron meiosis writing parent
nocturnal beam with a battery go
sometime captain and that's when to join
use a little ants implies resident is
inspired by now contracts visa plus
worship to be the same oh good that was
shorter novel what a cliffhanger on that
one alright the author publishes books
had highly accelerated almost inhuman
pace maybe it's a robot in fact he has
put out more books in one year than most
authors doing lifetime going ahead
library and there's still a large amount
of material is written but not published
one cannot help the wonder where he get
so much done in so little time I did the
calculations and the numbers simply do
not add up maybe he can stop trying no
such mechanism exists in this world that
actually possible in your home dimension
no I just saw it in the movie once
about two beers and stuff you're going
through these bags are pretty fast
actually it's mostly pitchers oh yeah
the other doesn't only writes books but
do you feel asleep sometimes we makes
books out of only pictures neat ok then
thank you for all that information can I
have any of your library cards can you
help me in this endeavor of mine I'm in
a conundrum
well find them maybe I can talk to this
guy and you'll be able to help me ahh
brings back memories yeah ok fine then
you do your thing
to help me can you al baiy and try to
look for fly machine with with my
binoculars for ages never saw such a
thing though you made with your eyes or
maybe I'm the one that's going crazy
yeah why am I seeing everybody has this
way that they are maybe that's unique
okay but either way that's a library I
can't get in there until I get a library
card so hopefully in the future there's
going to be someone in the different
direction that I could have gone with
the big arrows glowing that way maybe
there but I'm gonna try here first to
them right next to it I'm lazy
I expect everything to be handed in it's
locked from the inside
well [ __ ] that wouldn't waste my goddamn
time why need not go down the way
hopefully Nico doesn't doubt my godly
knowledge there's nothing really smart
good this looks dark and dreary trash
bin trash bin oh oh marklar did you see
what happened yeah my vision went blank
for a second and then I saw something
like a really short dream I wonder what
that was about
no no buy your trash gross
maybe you should worry about this Nico
alright so I'm gonna go this way first
is because I'm going to hit all my
targets first hopefully I don't forget
about something because I've done that
within the past
boy this is a puzzle this is a long and
winding puzzle what if this big plastic
disc in there the supposed to go in
something my Markab are we really gonna
take these with us but they look so
heavy all right yeah you carry those
Nico Oh actually pretty light okay good
the big book tenses understanding robots
can I get okay can I tell me what taming
is god damn it okay coffee cups a photo
of someone lanterns land no thank you
for working so hard mister Lamplighter
all that's so nice
alrighty then jar full of red glowing
lose it
dictionaries words are unlined most of
the words are online okay weird someone
an obsessive lift there know some peon
woo where am I now
oh hi alright coffee sales manometers
turn around pretend like I never saw
that because I was the horrifying sight
and then I'm gonna go down here and see
if there's anything here that I need to
know about right carry on it there's so
many twisting - whoa markiplier did you
see that Fox just now grandma in the
tree huh got the Fox I saw in my dream
I'm sorry if you're looking for me but I
cannot talk to you not now
uh
but can you promise me something okay if
you can find a way to return please do
huh what do you mean by that or reply
hello hello there's no one here gone
like a shadow in the night I have no
idea where you want mysterious
fortune-telling box
hello please do not approach ooh
okay well that's glitched out and weird
breathing I'm sorry I can't help you
feel kind of bad about that but
hopefully well you're gonna find a way
to get out of here soon okay I'm gonna
go this way cuz there was another way to
go over here right he quick what is this
hello faded flier faded flyer anymore
faded flyers ah graffiti curious marking
on the wall looks like a ram do I have
anything that was Ram like I got a lot
of lenses I got a better the hell day in
this department
alright ok please Ram over there so
maybe if I believed like a ram be able
to open the door and hopefully go
through ok it's really warm in this room
jeez I'm a cat no I mean me ghost [ __ ]
person not again they're very very
distinct distinction okay oh you lost me
do you wish to join us join your cats
yes but I'm not a cat and I'm walk on
four legs like they did you have cat
eyes my eyes are normal people eyes all
known back home your hat is shaped like
a cat but I'm just a person you are
still welcome here
I protect lost people as well thanks I'm
not lost
I've got margov are the God in my head
the guide me speaks to me in my dreams I
see no oh that's so nice
warm here yes this was my original
purpose watching cats warm oh it's a
nice purpose yeah no you signed you
wished list
I can't sleep now markiplier and I got
stuff to do nice also is that my bed
well creepy but at least there's other
cats there I mean there's cats there
period not other cats just catch in
general nothing really do descriptive
about that just generally there's cats
there I'm gonna talk this word copy guy
hey buddy
hey kid you want some soup dumplings
guaranteed contained only a minimal
amount of industrial byproducts Oh
I'll pass okay goodbye alright then
alright smells kind of nice
what is it better fish i toasted the
bread myself in my head see gross okay
glad Niko thinks that's just as gross as
I do
are you for your photos no alrighty then
I'll just uh stand here alright then
hello there's a slot here looks like
paper or something might come out of it
it didn't do anything can you get a
picture taken please okay then huh joy
needs film mini an empty rectangular
slot I have a lot of lenses okay concave
convex then thick
about that hmm pretty dick I guess I
wasn't the right combination okay well
are we just gonna be trying here for a
bit all I gotta know if anything is
right or wrong
I've always start with the pig and we go
with the end and we do the concave
convex and concave well I'm just gonna
be I'm just going to be throwing like
guesses out there and there's got to be
some guide because there's too many
combinations there for me to actually do
something
Sam smells a little bit like burnt sugar
get the sugar in the ham Megan these
fried candy skewers nowadays you battle
you all oh okay thank you I want one
Hey ready for me to blow your mind
yeah okay so I'm Dan imagine that
prepare everyone for the upcoming water
shortage all you gotta do is dissolve
all these pills in water and then you
drink the water and then you never need
to drink water again what it also makes
plants grow faster it's got what plants
crave electrolytes how does that work
here why don't you take a free sample
oh thanks don't hey B you youngs bit
rude okay but if you gave me a free
sample I'll never need to get more from
you so I guess you just destroyed your
business in one fell swoop here and I
don't want to tell you how to run your
run your business but I don't need to
come back and why we didn't bring your
oh sweet it okay fine then I'm gonna go
down this weird lonely road that I don't
really understand this is me as a means
of getting a little more sinister
industrial okay in order to gain further
access to the lab you must pass a
security system test B what you must
change the color of lies in your
specific configuration
allow me
two lines correct access enough oh
alright three lights correct excess
tonight okay four lights correct that's
denied all right I'm close
[Music]
okay so that was one of the correct ones
oops
oh there's another there's more collars
wait five lights correct all right then
I didn't even need to worry about the
other colors I just need to do that
procedurally and apparently I got it
okay thank you
where am I now what am i doing
Oh God my robot what happened I don't
know I left for a minute and oh god
please do not approach that's not good
what am I gonna do I don't know
oh no no no no ll feel bad but it is
that it don't know what to do oh man
there's so many rooms to go and it's all
so confusing monitoring monitoring
monitoring there are a lot of computers
they look important to the square
particles just took out two my robots
and Glenn
might have to put off the water analysis
project for now monitoring and
monitoring picking up some more
disruptions in saturated city it's
consistent with our earlier findings
don't good it all not good at all the
Behrend energy I just reported another
sighting of the particles in the cliff
area nothing you're new at this point
alrighty then hmm I wonder what the
author would do in the situation top
still point usually references his works
mm-hmm none of us is leaving very well
out of recent vents square particles
took out a few my robots last week and
you go sleep alrighty then never mind I
can barely keep my eyes open man how
does dr. zip one get all that energy
okay then oh so this is all subsections
of the same same hub here so these
aren't just a lot of doors they're just
doors to different areas you drive at
you're malfunctioning and a frightening
rate physical damage from square
particle anomalies it's almost
impossible to reverse your living person
could dodge them unless they have a
death wish
if we're lucky sometimes a square go
well now before taking one the robots
arms or legs or do okay
weird this one is inactive oh we're
waiting to be repaired
oh we're waiting to be repaired oh wait
need to be repaired what about this
guy's back oh well waiting to be
repaired okay everything I cannot stop
spinning will not stop Manang is so
tedious I miss the good old days before
our repor robot repairing robots broke
down now the robots have to be assembled
by actual people but aren't you a robot
no I mean do I sound like a robot to you
not really
well your head is a TV what does that
have to do with anything already never
mind this place is weird a roo boot key
then have a good day everybody I suppose
I know what to do about a this but I'm
gonna carry on whoo
oh shoot if I'd known you would be here
so soon I wouldn't have I would have
turned off the darn lock hello there
sorry about the weird security measures
it's okay
markiplier helped me solve it good day
now hey know can I help you today yeah
you know I get a library card a library
cred not that library for that I tried
you needed to be the head librarian but
I can't get in without a library card at
the same time she's want to give that
library card really that's that like
George alright sorry Connor on a bad day
oh wait I know I can give you my library
card it won't be hard for me to get
another one wow thanks
there you're all set I think wait shoot
I forgot the front desk library robots
have facial recognition and my photo on
the card will match you once I tape a
photo of my face to your face haha
Deadpool style that was a joke who knows
maybe you'll get lucky and the robot
will take it anyway where comes the
worse you can always find somewhere to
take a photo I know where to do that I
have the lenses with which to do that so
you've been walking all over the world
huh mm-hmm
geez I can't imagine do you really get
tired sometimes
kind of but I don't mind it's actually
really pretty yeah I'm glad you think so
even with the Sun gone the world is
still a beautiful place what did the
world look like before the Sun Oh or
with the Sun huh yeah it's kind of
embarrassing to admit how little of it
I've actually seen Oh ironic isn't and
on the world leading researcher hi dude
Sears stay and build robots there's the
one exploring the world that just write
down the data crunch tsunamis generate
graphs right I've been seeing robots
everywhere
I just thought it was because the world
was too dangerous for most people to
explore that's not far from the truth
actually I know someone who still does
his research firsthand
Oh even after segments of Landstar
collapsing and access to more remote
areas became difficult I mean the al-rai
built a machine that could why something
we all thought was not physically
possible that's I asked him about
working with us so he provides us with
all sorts of insights from time to time
but for some reason he really didn't
want to build robots or more
specifically coding them oh come to me
I mean he's happy to work with robots in
fact he even ha been a while since we
talked must be busy with its books now
yeah talking about the author
something's poking up himself
- but glitter glue you can have that if
you want I mark millar decreed that I
must have this glitter glue I don't care
what you say never know when you need to
glitter things up right are you sure
halftimes of those thank you
all righty then bookshelf right yeah
other insights to say don't overwork
yourself okay your journey is just as
important as your end goal in cliche but
true alrighty then thank you I didn't
even get your name k markiplier doesn't
that lady look kind of familiar to you I
wonder if she's related to the robot
lady who gave me the amber I almost want
to ask her about it
should i yes you should actually I was
going to say that but it's hard to tell
with just so little details on people's
faces here amber okay oh that's how did
you get this
this robot lady in the Barrens gave it
to me she looked kind of like you I see
it was supposed to be such a
breakthrough you know I even based on
myself so I'll know it works
Rickford we wanted to build a robot that
acts like a person thanks like a person
rather than that isn't bound by its own
code oh it turns out you can't really
build something like that how many
contradictions in the code made her
unstable that was the only time I've
ever seen a robot guild rogue Gary's
there my life tell you what rogue but
she seems so nice when we talked
even if she talked a little weird and
she's been repaired for some time now
my friend was able to stabilize her
volatile state through his own means
real miracle work for that after he was
through she did ended up turning out
just like how I wanted the damage was
already done gave up on her back then we
all did shows you realize that now she
won't ever come back she won't even
answer my letters
sorry sorry family he's old onto that
amber okay I will
that's sad like that
that's so weird like this world is weird
and just into the terms of like what it
builds and what it thinks is possible it
can build robots but it can't fly like
this is bizarre hello human essence
indexable liquid read faster decreased
by a factor three point five seven
percent this week alarming to say the
least as the sharpest decline I've seen
and the numbers only
we left it there to concentrate the
fossil now there could be of any use
Todd believed but there's good chance
the city could run out of light and as
little as six months what are we going
to do I've got the Sun hooray me I'm a
hero with a god in my head I'm sorry you
have so little faith in me
they'll be here to go one color at a
time I already did it to you picking my
body has a robot in in help this is the
brain of room where machine parts are
made also robots I also have to write
down previous attempts I did it already
claw I already know what I'm doing just
stop telling me what to do huh I've got
a god in my head
well disease giving me advice well balls
fails wait for the puzzled resent slow
you're good I got the hard one is I'm
genius
sub ha stop yeah alright then and that's
hopefully now that we've the library
card we just need to get a photo taken
and then hopefully we can put this on
this bad boy with this glitter glue and
then also by the way I have don't I have
that weird free sample yeah but water
pill but I have a water pill in the
tuber water so put the pill in the water
dissolve really fast
I've got medicated water I don't know
what to do with that but I got it weird
huh okay so they've got to be got to be
like um it's got to be some sort of
thought to this actually yeah I need to
take a picture for reasons well I got
good news and bad news good news is that
the photo Center is right behind me bad
news that it doesn't work you're
catching on quick
after operations ended the baron's the
place got shut down all the engineers
lost their jobs and became street
vendors maybe markiplier and i can
figure it out from them that could
certainly help out people with expired
IDs like me okay then so you street
vendors huh just to be one of the camera
engineers right the camera huh joyous
memories
be thick and thin together by that I
mean the concave lenss did ah-oh concave
one through thick and thin so concave is
in between thick and thin can you tell
me how to 5th examiner it's been a while
British judge that pulls you lens goes
on one the end but I forget which one
okay
through thick and thin huh concave goes
through thick and thin
bulgy on the ends got it there anything
you remember about how to work the
cameras want to see when arranging the
lenses make sure the thin lens position
you position between the two curved ones
[Music]
concave through thick and thin that
might be enough to do it concave through
thick and thin so it's in between thick
and thin oh no it goes through thick and
thin so it might be on the side and one
between the two curved ones okay I can
get this all right yes certainly thick
lines should be positioned to the left
of both the curved lenses okay so thick
between the curved concave through thick
and thin so it's thick concave thin
other one got it got it I think I got it
so thick no not that this stop that
thick they're concave that thin
map cog axe slap her jungle hey look at
that I gotta get my picture taken
oh do I look good geez my blind mind
flooby-doo okay then I got that it's a
photo of me oh my eyes always this big
yes absolutely
Niko your eyes are freakishly big and
they light up my life okay it's working
now hey it's working
markiplier knoppix the camera sweet
alright then we're gonna go downstairs
maybe take a nap to this weird heater
guy that'd be I'd be kind of chill I
think pretty chilly I guess yeah oh yeah
oh yeah down here hey can I make it a
nap by you where did you find all your
cats they found me of their own no I see
a year no ah it's good that you're not
alone at least I'm not some robot from
the other areas stationed all by
themselves felt kind of bad with robots
it's alright we're not like people we
are typically unable to feel loneliness
right well you talk less like a robot
that most other robots I've met maybe
not many people were equal in this part
of the alley
but there are you one of them even lives
here
I see been here for a while I sure you
do not wish to stay I'm gonna thank for
offering them okay well apparently
Nico's good but I'm unfortunately all
the time which means I got to shut down
the world on him so thank you everybody
so much for watching hope you're doing
it this far like I don't know how far we
are from the tower but we got a library
card and we're going to glue our picture
on that bad boy and get into this
library and decipher this look so thank
you everybody so much for watching and
as always I will see you in the next
video bye bye
[Music]